Why is Corona virus killing more men than
women at a higher rate, killing men than women?
Early, we had just the case numbers and death
numbers from China, and we immediately saw
a much higher rate of death for men than for
women.
And the suggestion was that in China, culturally,
men smoke more than women.
Men are much more likely to be smoking cigarets.
And we know cigarets weaken your respiratory
system.
They can depress your immune system.
And because coronavirus seems to vary a lot
depending on the underlying health condition
of the person infected.
Men were more likely to die in China because
men are much more likely to be smokers.
It seemed plausible in any case.
The trend, though, is continuing in a lot
of different countries and we are now seeing
that in Italy, men are 60 percent of the cases,
but 70 percent of the deaths.
In South Korea, more women have tested positive,
but yet the deaths are 54 percent men.
The U.S. so far is not releasing this detail
of a detailed level of information.
So we don't know what's going on here.
The U.S. should start releasing that data.
But in total, for all countries where we have
data, men are about 50 percent more likely
than women to die after being diagnosed.
Now, remember, 50 percent can mean if women
have a 2 percent death rate.
Men have a 3 percent death rate.
That's 50 percent more.
I don't want.
Well, to misunderstand the numbers around
that.
So what's at play here?
The smoking issue does seem to be a factor
in possibly alcohol consumption as well.
We have world data from five years ago and
five years ago, 36 percent of men over age
15 smoke where only seven percent of women
over age 15 smoke.
That's a big difference.
And if indeed smoking is a essentially a co-morbidity
with coronavirus, that is important.
Meanwhile, alcohol consumption consumption
for men is eleven liters where it's two leaders.
For women, that may be a factor.
We saw that SaaS and Murs also had higher
death rates for men than women.
So it seems not unique to Koven, 19.
And there is also a general evolutionary idea
that maybe women have stronger immune responses
to viruses in general because of pregnancy,
essentially being living nine months of your
life with a foreign body inside of you.
It may confer some kind of survival advantage.
There could be a hormonal element to this.
And then also actual preexisting conditions
appear to be a factor.
We know that preexisting conditions increase
mortality for covered patients.
Check out some of the gender differences.
Men more likely to have heart disease than
women, stroke than women.
COPD, a lung disease and slightly more likely
to have high blood pressure.
All of these conditions are known to increase
the death rate from coronavirus.
So the takeaways are the death rate is remaining
higher for men than women in all of the countries
providing data.
We initially heard this out of China.
Other countries providing us this data seem
to be confirming the same thing.
Number two, the U.S. is not providing data
of this type and the U.S. really should start.
So that that's the second takeaway.
We're going to continue following this and
see see sort of where we come up as we get
more data.